hello there this is Steve Kaufman here
today I want to talk a bit about my
recent experience where with my Russia
where I have started speaking now with
the tutor and I've started writing and
having my writing corrected with in link
and you know I have spent two years
doing a lot of listening my major
activity in my language learning has
been listening 70 percent or so or more
I recently got a new tool by the way is
my little iPod Nano and here are these
tremendous earphones made by roots early
I guess made somewhere in China but
distributed by roots 14 dollars I can
take them running sounded tremendous and
I got our how much I know how much stuff
on here
I used by iTunes and way there go so
most have been listening but now I've
decided I want to work on my output
because when I speak Russian I make a
lot of mistakes so my first session with
my tutor I did probably well for about
15 minutes I seem to be able to remember
words I was able to say things and all
of a sudden I just got tired I think you
know you just get tired and all of a
sudden when you're tired you can't
remember things as well I guess it's
like performing in sports so I was
exhausted after 20 minutes I wanted to
go to there
it spoke for half an hour then I wrote
two pieces which were corrected by my
tutor and of course the way it works in
link it when it's corrected all the
inappropriate phrasing is is made into
correct phrasing so the result may not
be elegant but it's it's correct Russian
so that I recorded that and I listened
to it many times
focusing on some of the some of the
cases and things of that nature not
trying to understand whether it's dated
for instrumental case or some other case
but just to know that when you say you
know miss do you know between something
like it's gonna sound like this rather
than like that so I did that and then I
had my second discussion with my tutor
and with all the effort that I put
writing and trying to think about the
language and how I wanted to say things
my second session with the tutor was
just a joy and I was able to speak for
60 minutes I wasn't tired at all and I
could have kept on going as well I was
thinking about this whole business of
speaking you know six months ago I can
easily would speak to someone in Russia
not even had a spoke sometimes on the
phone which Anna who is the wife of Mike
our programmer they're both Russian and
and but it was tiring because I didn't
have the words I couldn't say anything
every session sort of ended in defeat
and I didn't enjoy doing it you possibly
it's good for me to do that but I didn't
enjoy doing it I far prefer listening
and reading and like right now when I'm
reading and I'm reading a book on but in
Mars in ski here on Stalin in Russian
and there's words of person I don't
understand but I enjoyed it so I was
quite happy doing right and of course I
listened I'm listening to a yama by
cooping here which is just a lovely
novel on the narrator his voice the way
he does it the dramatization is just
tremendous
very happy but now I am drawing the
output and I think what I take away from
that is in the language learning
you should sparked start to speak and
I've said this before you could start to
speak when you feel like speaking there
should be no obligation to start
speaking until you feel like me and for
some people that's early and and of
course it depends on your situation now
if if you're in a hurry to improve your
spoken language then it's conceivable
that you start speaking earlier but I
was in no hurry so it didn't matter to
me I just want to check to see if my
sound thing is still working yes it is
okay so I was in a hurry and so I waited
and I was happy that I was doing that if
I had neither some pressure to improve
my speaking perhaps I would have started
speaking earlier and I would certainly
combine the speaking with writing and I
would do what I'm doing with the writing
which is every time I get
corrected writing back on link I
recorded and I'm hoping to get a native
speakers who recorded for me I tried to
get my to turn up the sound on skype
wasn't good enough and then I have now a
playlist in iTunes which is going to be
my recorded writing in Russian and I
will be gradually accumulating more and
more examples of what I tried to say in
Russian but corrected turned into real
Russian that I record that hopefully a
native speaker records for men are going
to listen to this and I will remember
the times that I tried to express these
thoughts and how I didn't express I
didn't use the right casar this year
whatever the right word and this is how
its expressed and so those things have
meaning for me they're sticky and I
believe if I continue doing this that I
can get fairly good in speaking Russian
correctly and I think I'll get there
faster than if I try to remember all
these explanations in English which have
little meaning for me I'm even hoping
that are going to in English I'm going
to chat with a person in our office
about different usage patterns in
English based on the ten questions that
I applied earlier who where what I saw
birds on and I'm hoping people will do
this in Russian and so then I can listen
to an explanation about Russian but in
Russian hopefully with a transcript that
I've been importing the link
saving words and phrases especially so
all of these ways are going to enable me
through this heavy emphasis on listening
to get a good feel for Russian so that I
can produce it nitrate but I think we do
you know everything you read about the
language teaching the teachers and what
they taught me to get people to say
things in class we're gonna play games
with them we're gonna have a project
we're gonna do a video we're gonna do a
YouTube all of these things are aimed at
getting people to use the planet and I
just wonder if that's all that useful
whether we aren't better off to let the
language capability kind of just state
and ferment and let people absorb words
let them develop some capability and
some weapons so that they can defend
themselves so that when they go to speak
that they have a better chance of having
an enjoyable experience
no I admit that I am learning Russian as
a dilettante I'm under no obligation
there's no hurry so I can afford to take
my time but I'm not sure I would have
gotten that much further doing it
differently I had lunch today with a
person who'd commented on my blog and
who lives in Vancouver who attended
University here and he goes to these
meet-up sessions where people meet to
talk to each other in different
languages and he says he regularly meets
people his interest is in Chinese he
meets people who after 3 years at
university can't speak are nowhere so
you know I'm not convinced that the
effort that is put in in fact I know
that I'm quite convinced that the effort
that's put on getting people to produce
the language early I don't make it it
speeds up the process however when you
are ready to speak it's probably a good
thing to do and probably if I were
disciplined enough or motivated enough
then at an earlier stage in my Russian
once a week to speak or to try to write
it's probably a good thing it Prime's
the pump it forces the brains the brain
to try and think of what's gonna sort of
building up in there but not necessarily
any more than that and then I think as
you get better you'll want to speak more
you'll want it right more like I firmly
enjoy writing in Russian and now I have
a phonetic keyboard that works on my Mac
so I don't have to figure out where
things are on the Russian keyboard I
love trying to express myself in Russian
and I think it's very good for my
Russian makes me more conscious more
observant I notice things more now when
I'm with the light
notice some of the spelling the little
squigglies that little sounds that be
there for the soft sound or whatever
they say all the server what I would
refer to as junk cold in Russian and the
funny ways that they spell the ma glue
is actually Malu which I know when I
read it but when I go to write it
sometimes I write it the wrong way as
well having to write it having to use it
forces me to be a little more German but
I wouldn't want to be put into that
situation until I had enough capability
in order for it to be a successful and
pleasant experience so all I'm saying is
I'm happy with the way my Russian is
going I'm happy to spend so much time in
a somewhat passive learning mode of
reviewing words and phrases and
listening and reading and doing out with
the Sun Lake of course but I'm also very
happy now to be engaged with a tutor
talking to her enjoying talking to her
writing getting her corrected writing
back with all of her comments and course
her words of encouragement so just to
say that yeah one final comment I want
some people say you know I still can't
speak as well as I would like Garlock
many of those people speak very well I
mean you can't be a perfectionist this
is for Anna in Brazil in particular you
speak very well don't be too demanding
of yourself now we're going to top this
off